Слава Україні!
Героям слава!
З цих слів київський екскурсовод Сергій Савченко розпочинає кожну свою екскурсію цікавими та несподіваними куточками української столиці.
Останні п'ять років він проводить екскурсії українською мовою, хоча раніше його робочою мовою була російська -
частково на вимогу колишнього роботодавця, частково через обставини.
Краєзнавча література в більшості своїй російськомовна. Усі маститі дослідники Києва пишуть російською.
І ти, проникаючи в цей світ, читаючи це, досліджуючи це, ти розумієш, що досліджуєш Київ, який є не те щоб російськомовне місто,
просто російська здається максимально тією мовою, якою ти хочеш розповідати про Київ.
Тому що про нього пишуть російською, відтак ти так само маєш бути ретранслятором оцієї російськомовної думки.
Сергій виріс у Києві в україномовній родині. У школі, оскільки друзі та однокласники здебільшого говорили російською,
у неформальному спілкуванні він теж користувався російською, але у восьмому класі вирішив спілкуватися українською в усіх сферах життя.
Єдиною сферою, де йому доводилося переходити на російську, стала його професійна діяльність.
Для мене було дуже важливим ось це відчуття Києва. Мені здавалося, що він живе у форматі такого
"витонченого міста, про яке можна сказати лише російською". Насправді ні.
Виявляється, що про Київ можна і треба говорити українською, від цього він стане ще вишуканішим і правдивішим зрештою.
Поступово Сергій усвідомив, що оповідаючи гостям російськомовний наратив про Київ,
він втрачає величезний пласт історії, культури і традицій найбільшого українського міста.
Можна все життя російською розповідати, толеруючи шлях Булкагова та Ахматової, і так і не прийти до Зерова, Підмогильного та Нечуя-Левицького
- до багатьох тих, які наші. Ми знаємо їх за шкільною програмою, але якось цураємося їх оживити і сказати, що Київ - це їхнє місто.
Сергій помітив, що також чимало російськомовних слухачів його екскурсій у спілкуванні з ним переходять на українську.
Я не можу сказати, що я розгубив багатьох людей. Так, була якась пауза, була якась можливість адаптуватися.
Але останніми роками я помічаю, що ці люди, з якими я давно не бачився і які в моїй пам'яті точно були російськомовними,
тепер приходять до мене на екскурсію, говорять між собою і звертаються до мене українською. Хоча їх того не просив.
Процес переходу російськомовних українців на українську з новою силою підштовхнули дії Росії - повномасштабне військове вторгнення.
Багато жителів сходу України через війну опинилися в західних регіонах і захотіли якщо не повністю перейти,
то хоча б достатньо вивчити українську мову. Допомогти таким людям покликаний проєкт безкоштовних курсів української.
Спочатку ми стартували як офлайн-групи з міста Києва.
Там було набрано понад десять груп офлайн. Потім з'явився запит в інших містах,
тобто у 2015 році ми були вже у 30 великих містах України. Потім хвиля пішла на спад.
Коли попит на офлайн-курси зменшився, активісти запустили онлайн-портал для вивчення української "Е-мова".
Але після 24 лютого очні заняття поновили. У Львові вони відбуваються у центрі міста - у будівлі Першої львівської медіатеки.
Наше основне завдання - допомогти людям перейти на українську, тобто це розмовна мова.
У нас нема таких лекторій, як в університеті заняття, щось на зразок цього.
Ми більше практикуємо мову і ми використовуємо, наприклад, в мене є група, яка має офлайн-заняття.
Вони спілкуються на певну тематику кожного заняття. Наприклад, це похід у магазин чи похід в аптеку, чи це релігійні свята, чи це традиції.
Війна внесла свої корективи до програми занять. На уроках, наприклад, наразі не обговорюють тему "домівка",
тому що для людей, чиї будинки були зруйновані, або для тих, хто був змушений залишити свій дім, це може викликати гіркі спогади.
Наталія Бугай родом зі сходу України і все життя прожила у російськомовному середовищі.
Переїхавши через війну до Львова, вона вирішила підвищити свій рівень української і частіше нею користуватися у повсякденному спілкуванні.
Усім своїм знайомим я рекомендую, бо, по-перше, рівень української мови став набагато вищим.
Я також трошки спілкуюся. І взагалі наші такі заняття дуже цікаві, вони проходять в такій ігровій формі,
ми читаємо цікаві книжки і просто спілкуємося один з одним. Це такий спосіб відпочити від повсякденності.
Після того, як у лютому розпочалася повномасштабна війна Росії проти України, багато українців вирішили повністю перейти на українську мову
і припинити спілкуватися російською, оскільки вона асоціюється з країною-агресором.
Ірина Зайковська, яка вивчала питання освоєння мови в Університеті штату Мічиган, називає цю ситуацію якщо не унікальною, то вкрай рідкісною.
Коли люди відмовляються від мови, яку вони раніше вважали своєю рідною, чи суспільство вважає, що це їхня рідна мова,
одночасно з переходом на іншу, ось це рідкісне явище.
Якщо подивитися на історію, каже лінгвістка, масово від рідної мови відмовлялися євреї, які тікали з Німеччини від націонал-соціалістів.
Цілком зрозуміло, що люди, які переживають травму такої сили, як і євреї, які виїхали з Німеччини в той момент,
коли їхньому життю почала безпосередньо загрожувати небезпека, у них не було іншої опції.
Їхня травма була настільки сильною, що жодного іншого варіанту вони для себе не бачили.
Євреї, однак, переходили на мови своїх нових країн проживання, тоді як російськомовні українці переходять на державну мову своєї батьківщини.
Опитування людей в Україні показували, що статистично більша кількість людей у ​​тих регіонах, де значна кількість людей говорять російською мовою,
наприклад, на сході України, кажуть, що російська - це їхня основна мова спілкування - у школі, вдома тощо.
І серед цієї ж вибірки більшість людей вказують на те, що українська мова є їхньою рідною мовою.
Очевидно, для українців - це випливає з цих опитувань - поняття рідної мови визначається вибором. Це символічний вибір.
У проєкті безкоштовних курсів української зазначають, що інтерес до переходу на українську мову прямо залежить від актуальних подій.
Коли розпочалася війна, ми бачили набагато більшу хвилю зацікавленості перейти на українську мову.
Групи були в рази більші. Зараз ця тенденція знову спадає, але ми сподіваємося,
що є люди, які дійдуть до кінця і змінять свою мову побуту на українську.
І навіть якщо не змінять - організаторів курсів це не лякає.
Вони стараються використовувати українську мову вже більше не в зовнішньому, а в домашньому побуті - це має бути бажання людини.
Тобто тут ти ніяк не навієш. Це має бути їхнє безпосереднє рішення.
З мого досвіду те, що я чула, від людей, які приходять на курси, це орієнтовно невеликий відсоток - це 25-30 відсотків.
Київський екскурсовод Сергій Савченко впевнений, що хоч шлях до українізації непростий, його неодмінно слід пройти.
Ми докладаємо для цього максимум зусиль для того, щоб своїми історіями, своїми прикладами надихнути і показати, що це
А) неболісно, Б) нескладно та В) життєво необхідно.
Це ж стосується і його рідного та улюбленого Києва, про який він на своїх екскурсіях із таким ентузіазмом розповідає - українською мовою.
Я думаю, що Київ, який був україномовним завжди всупереч міфам, які породжували у радянському ХХ столітті,
знову стане україномовним в переважній своїй більшості, левовій частці.
Бо це столичне місто і це українське місто. Було, є і буде!